and joining me now is Corey Lewandowski
Trump's 2016 campaign manager and
co-author of the new book Trump's
enemies out next Tuesday an Antwon
Searight former senior adviser to the
Hillary Clinton campaign in South
Carolina and the CEO of blueprint
strategy thank you both for being with
me tonight hello Lisa so Anton I want to
start with you
hi Corey I want to start with you Antwon
if there's potentially new information
here it's oversights committee's job is
to investigate why wouldn't they look
into it
well Lisa this is a prime example of why
the Republicans lost control of the
Congress just a few weeks ago on Tuesday
November 6 they have investigated
themselves into the minority here we are
once again wasting taxpayers dollars on
something that does not exist they spent
so much time focusing on Hillary Clinton
that they have not spent time putting
forth a policy agenda that will move
this country forward and the voters
respond the way they did on Tuesday
night well Courtney what do you make of
wet antwuan just said I mean isn't is it
isn't it the oversights committee's job
to conduct oversight well look of course
Lisa and if new information is available
mark meadows and the committee have an
obligation to the American taxpayers
into the Constitution to do their job to
investigate wherever that may lead so
let's be very clear we all know that the
Clinton Foundation was not on the
up-and-up my only disappointment was
that the Congress has taken this long to
continue the investigation that it
wasn't done for the Justice Department
prior to now there is no way that the
individuals or those countries from
overseas that gave tens of millions of
dollars for access to the Clinton
Foundation when either when she was a
Secretary of State or after we're doing
so out of the goodwill because what
you've seen now is that the Clinton
Foundation is not receiving those types
of donations anymore so clearly it was a
pay-to-play scam and now this should be
a much larger investigation to bring it
to light because the Clintons have
always operated it's one set of rules
for everyone else and a different set of
rules for them course that's the truth
you just hold on I want to ask you die
I'm gonna follow up on what Cory just
said if we've seen a drop-off in
donations if donations weren't meant to
get access to Hillary Clinton why the
drop-off
that just means for
have people and moved on and maybe the
Clintons have moved on and courting
those donors Cory just swallowed the
biggest pill of hip-pocket sparkly I've
ever seen now here we have the president
and the Republican majority trying to
put strike fear in the American people
about investigation after investigation
if the Democrats take over the Congress
and now you're saying here tonight Cory
that it's okay the Congress has a
responsibility to investigate so which
one is it you can't have your cake and
eat it too and friends we know this is
the seconds to drive a wedge into the
real issues in this country and separate
Democrats from Republicans and that's
what this is all of it well Congress has
an obligation to investigate and they
should investigate Clinton and Comey and
McCabe and go into the email hold on
Trump Ivanka Trump did not bleach spit
33,000 emails on a private server or
have classified emails on her own server
and say whoops I didn't know the
Secretary of State or as a former US
Senator that I can't store classified
information on my own private server she
never did that
let's go and investigate Hillary Clinton
for putting out classified information
onto Huma Abedin server of which her
ex-husband had access to the FBI knew
about it and didn't prosecute any of
them but actually gave them leniency
because they claimed that
attorney-client privilege between them
all caramel's Huma Abedin and Hillary
Clinton cores read the book or all the
information Antoine Antoine does it so
there's none of this concern you at all
I mean you look at it one of the things
that we know the DOJ is looking into
potential pay-to-play you look at things
like The Associated Press reported about
Clinton donors getting access to Hillary
Clinton with meetings you know that
about Ron Berger Grand Prince went to
the Clinton Foundation to try to get
access to Hillary Clinton when he
couldn't get to her via the State
Department you look at things like the
International Business Times reporting
that arms sales increased the Clinton
Foundation donors how does none of this
concern you Lisa what you and Corey and
I both both know all three of us know is
that if there was an inch of wrongdoing
by the Clintons it would have
headline front and center all the way
through every news outlet and
investigation would have been the top
front and center of this networking
every other right-wing network you can
imagine you and I both know that there
is no there there and I think we're
going to find this out and this is just
a last straw by the Republicans who are
going to make their way to the majority
next year to try to raise the issue that
where there's no issue well Cory we
don't know that yet do we I mean the DOJ
is looking into this we actually don't
have those answers really place well
they're looking into it Antoine Cory
well we don't know what the bottom line
is but what we do know is that the
Inspector General is still looking at
the crooked members of the FBI whether
that's Comey over Co here's your page
look that's a fact the IG is looking
into those people the Deputy Director of
the FBI has been referred to a criminal
referral for lying under oath on three
separate occasions we know that they
were part of the Clinton team that Bruce
or Nelly or who is his wife was part of
fusing GPS they're all tied to the
Clinton cabal and we're going to find
out once and for all what they did to
try and subvert the will of the American
people and if they were involved in any
way shape or form in falsifying a FISA
application to spy on American citizens
because if Donald Trump wasn't elected
we wouldn't know anything about those
things one real quick Corey bless your
heart you've done a good job of
repeating the facts but you know and I
know that that's a different sailor
reality and that's fact that's fixing
that fact
all right well happy Thanksgiving it's a
good for Happy Thanksgiving to you too
my friend
happy Thanksgiving to you both thank you
gentlemen